here our Lord clear as they John 151
to10 I'm the True Vine and my father is
the gardener he takes away every branch
that does not bear fruit in me now don't
you dare butcher this if you're not a
Christian you're not in Christ he's not
talking about Muslims and Hindus those
who are in him the way you are in him is
by believing in him so it's talking
about those who are united to Christ
he prunes every branch that bears fruit
so will bear more fruit pruning purging
the idea is to purge cutting cutting is
something that's painful
folks you are clean already because the
word that I've spoken to you remain in
me and I will remain in you condition
huh and he's talking to the disciples
one of whom who did not remain was
Judas notice conditional
I used to explain these away as a
calvinist oh these are not prescriptive
they're descriptive thanks to the LIE of
jam white just as a branch cannot bear
fruit by itself unless it rains in the
vine so neither can you can you unless
you remain in me I am the vine now how
do you remain in him he's going to tell
you I am the vine you are the branches
the one who Reigns in me and I in him
Bears much fruit because apart from me
you can accomplish nothing if anyone
does not remember remain in me he is
thrown out like a branch notice you are
in him but you got to remain and if you
don't you're caught off just like Romans
11 says Paul agreeing perfectly with his
master his
Lord and dries up and such branches are
gathered up and thrown into the fire
this is Hell friend and are burned up
now how do you remain in
him how do you remain in him
let's
see if you remain in me and my words
remain in you see my words in you my
commands ask whatever you want it will
be done for you my father is honored by
this that you bear much fruit and show
that you are my disciples that's how
you're going to know you're a true
disciple remaining in him keeping his
words but notice you don't remain in him
by keeping his words you're cut off here
it is just as the fathers loved me I
have also loved you remain in my love
and here how you do it if you obey my
Commandments damn I guess Jesus is
teaching faith and
works let me hear fully full
screenshot what are you guys not
getting faith and works huh
just as I have obeyed my father's
Commandments love now because Father and
Son Spirit are inseparable immutable the
Lord Jesus cannot but obey the
father Spirit cannot but obey the father
and the son that's their nature it's
unchangeable unlike us our nature hasn't
been made immutably morally
Incorruptible so we can choose to then
not remain his love by disobeying him I
mean honestly do I need to go on Beyond
this did everyone get it I'm not done
yet and I'm going to open up to you
guys all right do you see it here again
in case you missed it now what does
obedience of faith
mean and I read this
already right remain in me and I In You
by obeying my word if you do not obey my
words you don't love me wewere this
right okay now watch
here what is OB ience of faith mean
again right here Romans 16:25 26 now to
him who's able to strengthen you
according to my gospel and the
proclamation of Jesus Christ according
to revelation of the mystery that had
been kept secret for long ages but now
is this close and through the prophetic
scriptures has been made known to all
the nations according to the commanding
to God to bring about The Obedience of
Faith what does obedience of faith mean
we're going to get there again acts 67
the word of God can contined to spread
the number of disciples in Jerusalem
increased greatly a large group of
priests became obedient to the faith
what is that Obedience of Faith what is
that 1 John 2 3-5 Now by this we know
that we have come to know God if we keep
his Commandments that's how you know God
knows you know him the one who says I've
come to know God yet does not keep his
Commandments is a liar and the truth is
not in such a person whoever obeys his
word that's what Jesus said you obey my
words by keeping my commands you remain
faithful to me then you're in me what
are you guys not getting what faith is
that's the whole point of James 2 but
Bible perverts like me steroids badly
and plastic
surgery butcher what Paul says
necessitating a corrective and James 2
is the
corrective to remain just
ified requires your obedience stop
defining justification the way Martin
Luther F
did whoever obeys his word truly in this
person the love of God has been
perfected by this we know that we are in
him still not getting it 1 John 322 to
24 and whatever we ask we receive from
him because we keep his Commandments and
do the things that are pleasing to him
now this is his Commandment that we
believe in the name of his son Jesus
Christ and love one another just as he
gave us the Commandment but wait how do
we believe in Christ remember John 3 36
by obeying Christ keeping the law of
Christ ah believing in Christ is
obedience to Christ where' I get that
from John 3:36 which we looked at and
the person who keeps his Commandments
resides in God do you see it you have to
believe in Christ which is obedience to
Christ to remain in Christ to be
faithful to Christ which is what faith
is and God in
him all right now by this we know that
God resides in Us by the spirit he has
given us now how do we know the love of
God for this is the love of God that we
keep his Commandments and his
Commandments do not weigh us down so
when you Bible pervert say the
Commandment no one can keep
them here John says his Commandments are
not hard are you saying he's
lying and notice again who gets saved in
Revelation can I watch here who is saved
according to Revelation Revelation 12:17
so the dragon became in Rage at the
woman and went away to make war on the
rest of her children who are her
children those who keep God's
Commandments you Bible Butcher and old
testimony about Jesus again Revelation
141213 this requires the steadfast last
endurance of the Saints though man how
many times obey obey keep abide
obeys God's Commandments and hold to
their faith in Jesus so how do I hold my
faith in Jesus obeying his
Commandments damn
Gina then I Heard a Voice from Heaven
say WR this blessed are the dead those
who die in the Lord From This Moment On
yes says the spirit so they
rest from their hard work because their
deeds not their confession will follow
them am I missing something here
repeatedly
repeatedly throughout the New Testament
Obedience of Faith obeying his
Commandments abiding in his Commandments
those who endure and persevere in
faith Cornerstone my articles are in
description box on YouTube go to YouTube
look at the scripts they're there it's
all yours free of charge okay now watch
this Paul talks about those who are
baptized if you are baptized you're
baptized into Christ to do what be an
obedient slave The Obedience of faith
and I'm still not done I'm gonna open
up it's New Testament Nick right
faith and works no there is no faith
that's not working what do you not get
and I'm going to put the icing on the
cake here Romans 6:16 and 23 do you not
know that if you present yourselves as
obedient slaves you are slaves of the
one you obey either of sin resulting in
death or obedience resulting
righteousness oh so The Obedience of
faith is
to do what exactly to be faithful that's
how Paul is defining Faith your
faithfulness but how do I show my
faithfulness obedience we're going to
get there I'm almost
done but thanks be to God that through
you though you were slaves of sin how do
they free themselves you
obeyed damn where is Faith Paul faith
and works Paul shame on you Paul you
obeyed from the heart that pattern of
teaching you're entrusted
to exactly Samuel Samuel got it brother
you got it faith alone means
faithfulness alone being faithful to
Christ Alone even though the word faith
alone is never used in the Bible except
in James 2:24 where it says you see
Brethren a man is justified by works not
by faith alone because he's dealing with
these Bible perverts who misde Define
faith all everyone got it how were they
freed from their sin by obeying from the
heart the pattern of teaching you're
entrusted to are we seeing this Romans
6:16 to
23 everyone got
it all
right and having been freed from sin how
by obeying from the heart the pattern of
teaching given to you teaching obeying
that teaching you became enslaved to
righteousness I'm speaking you terms
because of the weakness of your flesh
for just as you once presented your
members as slaves to impurity and
lawlessness leading to more lawlessness
so now present your members as slaves to
righteousness leading to sanctification
for when you were slaves of sin you are
free with regard to righteousness so
what benefit did you did you then reap
notice it
doing sewing to reap from those who
those things that you are now ashamed of
for the end of those things is death but
now freed from sin and enslaved to God
you have your benefit leading to
sanctification and the end is eternal
life for the payoff of sin is death but
the gift of God is eternal life in
Christ Jesus our lord in fact let me
show you something let's go here see if
it's in this
article okay so it's probably this one
here let me let me find it yep here uh
the other one right here right here
watch
here black and white reaping right how
do you receive eternal life here you go
Galatians 6 7-9 do not be deceived God
is Not mocked whatever a man SWS that's
something you do sowing is something you
do this he will also reap for the one
who SWS to his flesh
if you do the Deeds to satisfy your
flesh Will from The Flesh reap
corruption but the one who SWS to the
spirit you do your deeds in unit the
spirit in obedience to the spirit from
the spirit reap eternal life let us not
lose heart in doing good over for you
clowns how do you reap eternal life by
sewing in unit to the spirit to the
spirit in other words doing what the
spirit commands you to
do Galatians 679 am I blind I mean how
many passages must I quote am I blind
here and Paul tells you what what it is
to se to the spirit because he gives you
a list Galatians 5:16 26 specifically
22:25 and notice the faith that saves
you is the fith that's working Galatians
55-6
the faith that saves you is the faith
that works through love it's a working
faith in other words it's
faithfulness out of love for
God Galatians 5 veres 5-6 and 22 is it
clear yes same thing that Clement said
and I will bring Clement a little later
is it
clear or wasn't it clear all right now
let's go to how Protestant exites Define
this term here you go I'm going to read
the notes Here Protestant
exes not me Protestant
exites not Catholic not Orthodox okay
watch here let's see Evangel
right all right let's
see what is obedience of Faith you guys
ready because you don't like it if we
quote Catholics or Orthodox all
right the phrase
ho is that how you pronounce it you guys
you Greek guys because
isos has been very stood watch here
Protestant all right you see it here
what does it mean let me go to My
article because I highlighted
here the phrase
hoos has been very simp says one and
objective genitive it's telling you what
it means because Paul writes things that
are difficult to understand at times a
reference of the Christian faith
obedience to the faith obeying the faith
hold on Buddy notice how you're saved
obeying the faith obedience to the faith
a subjective genitive The Obedience
Faith produces also you mean having
faith produces being faithful and
obedient no come on and attributive
genitive meaning believing obedience so
Paul was calling them to believing
obedience or is a genitive of apposition
meaning obedience which is Faith damn
that's what I
said and apposition means it's
explaining what faith
is to be
obedient damn need a
facelift isn't that what I
said hey you mean the
Protestant confirmed what I said